no I'm not dating right now but I love
life I'm really just enjoying my life
and my time with my baby and family
Khloe Kardashian is still in no rush to
give up the single life and apparently
neither is her sister Kylie Jenner this
according to a source exactly a source
tells et despite speculation that Khloe
and Tristan Thompson are rekindling
their romance the rumors are not true
I'm so fine not dating right now so why
did fans think the two were getting back
together because Khloe has been wearing
an old necklace Tristan got her but our
source says she wears it simply because
she likes it oh and there's this moment
from the new Keeping Up trailer last
night the two were said to be in a good
place right now and their priority is
and always have been their baby true the
couple split in February following that
cheating scandal with Kylie's former
friend Jordan woods
now as for Kylie's love life our source
is also shutting down any rumor that the
makeup mogul is back with her ex Travis
Scott saying kylie is single the source
goes on to say their priority is also
their daughters stormy there is no bad
blood at all between them it's nothing
but love and that they're just taking
some time to figure things out oh and
Kylie's not back together with her other
ex Tyga either our source says as for
the rest of the Kardashian's we're
hearing the sisters are enjoying being
single at the same time well except for
Kim of course according to our source
Khloe Kylie kendall and Courtney's
priorities have changed and now their
attention is just focused on their
family and spending time with each other
which will all be addressed on the new
episodes of Keeping Up I feel like we
just need to press a reset button you
guys gotta get
to the fact that we're just family
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]